[Música]
economía en directo américa daniela todo
el mundo estaba esperando la respuesta a
la pregunta que yo estaba avanzando en
los sumarios porque cayó la producción
de autos en octubre en mexico bueno le
dijo primero cuánto cayó 25 9%
exactamente en octubre comparado con el
mismo mes del año pasado y este
resultado se atribuye a la escases
global de semiconductores que obligó a
varias plantas de este país a suspender
la producción de vehículos antes era la
pandemia ahora es la
escasez de chips sólo en octubre fueron
ensamblados 257 mil automóviles 90.000
menos que hace un año ahora veamos las
plantas más afectadas fueron general
motores con una caída de casi el 70 por
ciento también quilla méxico volkswagen
y audi esta industria es bastante
importante para méxico raúl porque
representa el 38 por ciento del producto
interno bruto nacional y también una
cuarta parte del pib de manufacturas más
que ningún otro sector
y el levantamiento de las restricciones
ideas en eeuu impulsa los precios del
petróleo bueno hay analistas como por
ejemplo jaypee morgan que dicen que la
demanda de crudo está volviendo a
niveles de antes de la pandemia este
lunes los aeropuertos de eeuu ya vimos
que estuvieron repletos de viajeros tras
la reapertura por supuesto de fronteras
para quienes ya estén completamente
vacunados el cierre de viajes no
esenciales estuvo vigente por 19 meses
para 33 países entre ellos algunos
claves como china india y brasil y
muchos de europa también pues eso raúl
más los nuevos datos que apuntan a que
estamos en una senda de recuperación
económica global llevó a los precios del
petróleo a 82 punto 57 dólares por
barril en el caso del w de referencia
para el golfo de méjico y 84 dólares el
del brent de europa en la pandemia las
cotizaciones del crudo se desplomaron
llegando inclusive a valores negativos
debido a que la demanda se redujo
notablemente en especial durante las
extensas cuarentenas que obligaron a
suspender toda clase de actividad pero
ahora que se recuperó la demanda los
precios están disparados y los países de
la opep que es la organización de
exportadores pues no han atendido las
súplicas de eeuu que dice que hay que
abrir más los grifos para estabilizar
esos precios y qué pasa en chile danny
porque los precios de la gasolina son
los que más están subiendo ahora en
general suben todos los precios de la
canasta familiar este año lo han hecho o
más bien en octubre 13 por ciento según
el departamento de estadísticas pero si
miramos todo el año corrido de enero a
octubre los precios al consumidor
acumulan un alza del 5 8% y los
productos que más suben son como lo
decía gasolina con alrededor de un 27%
acá lo vemos y gas licuado de petróleo
con un 30,6 por ciento estos los
primeros meses del año en los primeros
10 meses algunas de las razones que dan
lugar a este incremento son pues las
ayudas que ha entregado el gobierno
nacional a las familias y los tres
retiros anticipados de pensiones no
quiere decir que eso sea malo lo que
quiere decir es que se ha elevado el
poder adquisitivo de las personas y a su
vez el consumo y eso hace es que dispara
de una vez los precios y qué va a pasar
daniela con la reunión de las
autoridades económicas en europa que se
reúne en bruselas
bueno inició el lunes hoy es el segundo
día este encuentro entre ministros de
economía y finanzas de la unión europea
hoy el debate gira en torno a las
reformas fiscales pendientes el lunes el
plato fuerte fue el aumento de la
inflación que sólo en 19 países de la
zona euro aumentó más del 4% en octubre
vemos que en chile es uno 34 por ciento
los precios al consumidor son un tema
clave en europa hoy en día pues han
estado impulsados por un alza sostenida
de la electricidad que ha la ha llevado
inclusive a máximos históricos en apenas
un mes le doy este dato 23 5% han subido
los precios de la energía en europa otro
de los temas que más preocupan a la
unión europea es la alta deuda pública
que desencadenó la paot la pandemia en
las reuniones que se llevan a cabo en
bruselas pues buscan acuerdos para
incrementar pues está mejor para bajar
esta deuda sin causarles traumatismos a
la economía danny y vamos entonces ahora
con la cifra del día la cifra del día
son los 450 mil dólares que cuesta un
tiquete al espacio en virgin galactic la
empresa del multimillonario richard
branson que dijo haber vendido ya 100
boletos desde agosto mucho más alto que
los 200.000 ó 250 mil que pagaron 600
usuarios entre 2005 y 2014 y el primer
viaje comercial será a finales de 2022
todavía hay tiempo todavía de tiempo
para ahorrar pero daniela yo qué pena
pero la sigue invitando por aquí
cerquita vámonos de una vez aparece ahí
está erika olavarría esperándonos
también ha vamos a pagar manos